towing the slab for the cubs today boy
he's got a lot of pitches doesn't me uh
slider sinker four seamer change up
cutter curve
but in reality what you're gonna see
from advert most times is a lot of
sliders and a lot of fastballs but we're
focusing on that changeup today
hopefully that's more prominent
and a swing and a miss he struck him out
and jd that is what he does when he's
carving up those righties with that good
tight slider bring up cesar hernandez
hernandez
with a ground ball through that seam and
it's going to be an infield hit
perfectly placed
duffy couldn't get it
romine had a long run over there and had
no play to make hernandez on second base
with an infield single and jimenez at
first with the same it brings up johann
moncada
that ball hit really well on the move
ortega that's going to be over his head
sox are going to get a couple
moncada is going to
stop at second with a double it's two
nothing that's one of the reasons tony
elevated moncada into the five spot he
gets a fastball down it's out over the
plate hits it off the wall almost out of
the park it produces a pair brian
goodwin bets two balls at a strike here
comes
this one popped up duffy sunglasses on
makes the call and the catch on the
outfield grass
carlos rodon on for his 19th start he's
getting a little extra time between
starts these days which is a good thing
his era of two and a half 149 strikeouts
and a hundred and four and two thirds
innings that's pretty impressive and
he's going to lean on that high for
semer and here it comes and he struck
him out looking
strike three call by field and culbreth
wilson contreras the two hitter for the
cubs
he got him didn't quite hit his location
but top of the zone 99
will play two away in the inning david
bodie the three hitter swing and a miss
how about that first inning for carlos
rodon theory garcia to lead off the
second against advertise here's a line
drive leaping backhand catch by andrew
romine the shortstop angling toward the
left field line in shallow left timed
the jump beautifully amid a nice
backhand catch way above his head two
outs and the batter now is carlos rodon
advert fires
and a swing and a miss and he does get
him one two three patrick wisdom will
lead off the second for the cubs
and he swings and misses on a slider
four batters four strikeouts for rodon
two away as ian happ digs in batting
from the right side
he got him on a slider
five punch outs early for carlos
two-nothing
careful on this first pitch
schwendell bobbles gets it to alzali
careful indeed he almost snuck one
inside the bag and schwendell able to
come up with it but brayu flied to
setter his first time
on the ground romine gathers it in
and al zalai gets him in order seven in
a row set down for at burke it's eight
nine and one for the cubs here in the
third so they'll turn the order over
swing and a miss strike three
eight batters face
six strikeouts for rodon two away in
rafael ortega the leadoff man swing and
a miss strike three three punch-outs in
the first two in the second two more in
the third he's got seven
already carlos wrote onwards to wilson
contreras
he's got eight
ninety-nine in the zone so runner on
second one away
he got him
on a slider
for his ninth strikeout and in scoring
position for the white sox here to start
the fifth zach collins at the plate
good job auslai went upstairs got him
with a fastball to finish him off 208
here in the top half of the fifth inning
it'll bring up tim anderson with a man
in scoring position
back up the middle body unloads nice
play wow he is a good defender so it's a
lead off walk by matt duffy ian happ a
strikeout victim back in the second
swinging in the miss he got him on 98.
andrew romine the shortstop will hit
he struck him out
he's got 11.
ironically this is a guy who hasn't
struck out swindell duffy and azelai the
only three in this lineup without a
strikeout
tapped
carlos has it little jump one bounce
throw to agree you how about that that's
a tremendous play a very inventive play
by carlos and it's out of the inning
hernandez to lead off the sixth inning
that's a good change up good job right
there as he strikes out hernandez
and nothing in two out of ray
and he got him swinging
two outs in a man at second johan
moncotta the batter
swing at a miss struck him out that's
your answer one more change up gets the
job done he struck out seven here today
ortega coming into the ballgame today it
hit in eight consecutive games
good played appearance right there and
ortega will take the walk tony comes up
he realizes that a healthy rodon heading
into the postseason is the best way
as bodhi stands in
ortega on the move that one bounce
through the left side hole base hit and
ortega won't stop he's at third david
boney delivers are at the corners with
one out frank schwendell now two out in
the inning with runners on first and
third and it's a two-run ball game
ground ball to third
monkata has it lots of time
and the stretch by abreu
to save his bacon it's still two nothing
socks
sucks in the seventh and the batter is
zach collins
drilled to right
going back his hat near the wall that he
makes the catch
it's going to be a nice ovation i know
that david ross pats him on the backside
albert also
excellent work dan wickler to try to get
the final out in this seventh inning
with a runner at third and two down
nice play by winkler loving that one
bring up cesar hernandez he's on with an
infield single also
scored flag ball out into deep left
center wisdom at the track it's gone a
home run
three nothing
two days
two homers
for cesar
after that home run he now equals abreu
again for the team lead
abreu
towering fly
and this one will also get out they go
back to back it's four nothing
he didn't like being tied at 20 homers
on the year
you see that's not good because i was
above just to say that we'll bring up
ian happ he's one for three with two
strikeouts here it comes
swing and a miss and the white sox shut
out the cubs a combined five-hitter with
17 strikeouts a season best